audrina patridge is baby shower is  pretty in pink  the former Hills star celebrated her  baby girl over the weekend and only et  has the photos from inside but 31 year  old is stunning in a figure hugging  dress surrounded by friends and family  as she proudly showed off that growing  baby bump Audrina is due in July but no  baby name is picked out just yet for me  choosing a girl name is the hardest name  we don't have a list and I figured  whenever she's born the tropical themed  shower was completely tickled pink pink  baby outfits pink cake covered in pink  roses  Audrina definitely wanted a piece of  that and one of her fiance Cory's old  surfboards was actually painted pink for  this little California girl  tons of treats were on hand and Audrina  was beaming congrats to this soon-to-be  mama